sir at Westpoint teaches literature to
students going to war
Elizabeth Samet discusses her book
soldier's heart this program from New
York City is about half an hour thank
you very much for coming just talk to
you a little bit about how this book
came about it's really been ten years in
the making although I didn't know that
at first soon after I arrived at West
Point I was sitting on a porch of a
Colonel's quarters that overlooked the
Hudson and his wife was staring at me
and then said to the assembled crowd be
careful what you say in front of
Elizabeth because one day she's going to
write a book about all of us at the time
though I didn't really know what that
book would be about because I was too
busy trying to figure out make my way
through a kind of forest of acronyms and
abbreviations inexplicable messages
would come my way full of strange things
telling me what to wear when to be at a
certain place and I would have to get
them deciphered by some of my military
colleagues took a while to get used to
military time any appointment afternoon
was dicey business for a while there I
never knew whether I was arriving at my
class on time but I came to learn over
the years several things that teaching
and writing the book reaffirmed it for
me that teaching at West Point is not
like teaching literature elsewhere that
I have learned more from my students
about literature about courage in
particular than I could ever teach them
and when I first arrived soon after I
arrived I was making my way to the
gymnasium and if you've ever been to
West Point you know it's the best
manicured place in the country and so
there was every day a man on his power
mower grooming making sure everything
was all right and one day he stopped me
and he shouted over his power mower and
he said miss what's your function and I
looked at him it's not a question I get
every day and he said what's your
function what do you do around here and
I said well I teach English and that's
really how I thought of it and I didn't
think of it as anything more than that
there were growing pains in the
classroom I knew it wasn't quite like
teaching elsewhere of course my students
all were uniform they all called me
ma'am
one day at general showed up in my class
and
down but we all carried on that's what
one does but it really in the beginning
didn't feel all that different once I
started to get used to the rhythms of
the place but it was after 9/11 in
Afghanistan and Iraq which shook West
Point the way it shook the rest of the
country that I began to think about my
function in different ways and that what
had originally been purely an
intellectual commitment became for me an
emotional one as well and suddenly we
were teaching literature in a new
context and that was brought home for me
a couple of years ago when we were when
I was teaching Macbeth to a group of
English majors West Point has academic
majors just like any other institution
although I don't think everyone realizes
that and we were reading along with
Macbeth the actor Garrick Jacoby's
thoughts on learning to play Macbeth and
he said that he understood the soldier
part and then he arrived at one of the
first great soliloquies and he said that
he was startled by it as many times as
he'd read it when he was thinking about
playing it he said here I had before me
an on thinking slasher a man of action a
soldier and suddenly I realized he was a
man of feeling - and one who was able to
create these wonderful images and who to
hit that he had a rich imaginative life
and I read that with the cadets and they
really got angry at Jacobi and they
don't think of themselves as
non-thinking slashers and as one of them
said to me I'm not an on thinking
slasher now and I don't think it rock is
going to turn me into one and so when I
say that literature is read in a
different context at West Point that's
really what I mean I never imagined a
scene like that when I was at graduate
school at Yale I never imagined reading
The Iliad with students who would be in
Iraq in a war zone within a year after
their graduation I never imagined that I
would get emails with subject lines that
said greetings from Mosul from an
infantry lieutenant who just returned
from Patrol and thought he might be male
his English professor and have a chat
about books and baseball and all the
things we're both interested in I never
imagined that I would get sand-filled
letters that would sort of pour out on
my desk from
another lieutenant a former student who
found himself in a Sunni triangle when
the Sunni triangle was not a pleasant
place to be and I never imagined also
that I would begin class one day not
administering but having administered to
me a survival exercise and so I wanted
to share that experience with you it was
a senior seminar I taught to the cadets
who were majoring in English and they
had just had a military science class
and this was in the fall of 2006 and
there were nine of them and they came
into the seminar comparing notes on an
exercise they just completed in their
military science class the conceit of
the exercise was that as a result of a
plane crash they'd be stranded in the
desert but only for a few days after
which time they were sure to be rescued
they were given a list of items they
could salvage from the plane and told to
rank them in order of their utility for
survival among the available items were
a raincoat a flashlight a parachute a
mirror a knife a pistol food and a
bottle of vodka fresh from my reading of
Santa Cruz win sand and stars all about
his many plane crashes in those early
days of aviation I was fairly confident
that I knew what to choose but when
saying exuberant
he didn't know that he would be rescued
so I was planning for the long haul
remember ma'am the cadets warned me as I
was taking the test you're gonna be
rescued in a few days those were the
conditions of the exercise but how I
asked them could anyone be so sure I
brought all the wrong things of course I
loaded myself down with food and weapons
when I should have brought the raincoat
to protect me against the cold desert
night the parachute to collect any rain
that happened to fall and the mirror to
signal a rescue plane some of the cadets
had fared well in the exercise while
others seemed as ill-prepared for the
crash as I was you could just take the
vodka ma'am said one of them that's what
I did
designed as a capstone experience for
those who majored in our program this
course on life writing demanded a great
deal of introspection from the cadets we
talked about their education about their
professional identities about the ways
in which technology had reshaped
concepts of the self sometimes when
class
/ we found that we had more to say and
those who had nothing scheduled for the
next hour stayed on to continue our
conversation even the most heavily
armored among them proved willing to
expose a great deal both in discussion
and in their semester long projects
which in fact ranged from a journal of a
Peruvian sojourn in the woods to a
volume of poetry that was illustrated by
hand all of our ruminations on education
training custom and tradition had a
different valence than they might have
when we were at peace and everything
seemed hypothetical just like an
exercise of being stranded in a desert
then one day toward the end of class the
cadets turn the tables on me ma'am one
of them said it's time you told us why
you teach here as often as I've heard
this question by now it always strikes
me a slightly bizarre it isn't what I
thought to ask any of my professors but
the idea that someone not in uniform
would want to teach those who evident
who are evidently still seems odd to
cadets usually the question comes from
the plebs which is what we call the
freshmen and they don't really know
entirely themselves what they're doing
or why these seniors however knew
themselves and they knew me quite well
and I had never found it so difficult to
answer their question which was in
effect just another version of that
groundskeepers question miss what's your
function I bet it's because of your dad
right offered one I agreed that my
father surely had something to do with
my coming to West Point he served in the
Army Air Corps in World War two but that
didn't explain why I stayed I like to
think I tried that I'm arming you with
something you may need something of
value but I also knew that whatever we
were discovering in that room wasn't
tangible that it lacked the particular
satisfaction of a well-built bridge
something they might learn an
engineering class were the marvelous
utility of a well named m16 which they
would learn how to use in their military
training but one day I hoped whatever it
was might help them in war and one day
it might help them come home not every
cadet believes that of course and
sometimes in the plebe literature class
which is offered in the spring term of
that first year to all of the cadets I
will get a skeptical cadet who looks at
me and says what does any of this have
to do with my being a lieutenant and
recently when I was writing some terms
up on the board one of the plebs this
was last year said I can't take any of
that to Iraq and it was a question of
course that but a lot of them probably
have on their minds but don't always ask
and it's a question that we as faculty
members have on our minds as well how do
we best prepare them for what we know
they're going to have to do so we
started talking about what they can take
to Iraq what they can take carry with
them in their minds as well as in their
they have these huge boxes that they
bring in fact one of my former students
was just telling me the books that she
filled this big box with among the other
things she could bring with her and of
course the realities of their situation
in Iraq are that there are moments of
high-stress periods of high stress mixed
with periods of boredom periods of
sitting around waiting for something to
happen and how they fill those hours I
think has a great deal to do with how
they feel when they return to the United
States after their deployments I there's
a in the old world war two Dell
paperbacks there was a message on the
back that said books are weapons and
when I first encountered that several
years ago I liked it I sort of made it
my mantra and and when cadets said you
know I can't take this to Iraq I said
well maybe you can not in the way you
think and I think that that kind of
terminology is it's sufficiently
combative for someone who teaches at a
military academy but I also think that
the value of literature of poetry in
particular poetry of genre I think that
can convey more truth several truths at
once is that it teaches cadets to
wrestle with ambiguity which is one of
the institution's priorities and I also
realize and I think the cadets realize
as well that they can take all the field
manuals they want but we know that this
conflict has many challenges for which
there are no answers there are no ready
solutions in field manuals and in the
regulations and that's when they're left
on their own and that's where I think a
rich imaginative life will help them in
very practical ways there's another
thing as well and that I believe poetry
literature but poetry in particular is
far more important to many of our allies
and our
than it ever has been to us and I think
that that's important in terms of
cultural awareness for them to recognize
I had a colleague friend of mine named
Al who was a lieutenant colonel and he
just retired from the Army but before he
retired he volunteered to deploy to
Afghanistan and he worked there with the
National Military Academy of Afghanistan
which actually models itself on West
Point and he had taught a few years
before the the poet Rumi in a class that
we gave to all the juniors at West Point
and he brought his little book of
Persian poets with him and he loved Rumi
and he kept reading him and he his
counterpart a colonel at the Military
Academy and Kabul
he brought the book with him to his
meetings and the colonel the Afghan
colonel was delighted that he brought
this book because he read Rumi as well
new Rumi by heart and al told me
afterwards he said you know I don't want
to say that this relationship would have
been a complete bust had I not brought
room a with me but it really helped and
it showed in particular he wrote to me
that he and the colonel were more alike
than alike and I think that it really
helped them as they were imagining their
curriculum and as they were imagining
how they might train military officers
for the Afghan army that this point of
connection was extremely helpful and so
in the answer the answer to the plebes
question I can't take that to Iraq was
actually for me sharing with him the
correspondence that I had had with a
former student and I wanted to share in
another passage a bit of that with you
it's a student named Andy I was actually
now in his third year of law school at
William and Mary he's the editor of the
Law Review there and after he graduates
he will become an army lawyer and his
motivation was his deployment he
actually had two deployments to Iraq and
he feels that our conflict there have
and the challenges it presents have
really outpaced our current notions of
the laws of land warfare and he thinks
he can make a difference by working as
an army lawyer his father was a general
so he knows how the army works but he
was also a bit of a rebel and that's why
I was quite fond of him in fact he knows
what it means to obey but he was most
remarkable in my class
so bang and I wanted to sort of
obedience and disobedience has obviously
been a both a professional and a
personal interest for a long time now
for me and so I just want to share a bit
of of what this particular students work
in the classroom meant to him as he was
deployed he was in a class on American
literature with man he was scheduled one
day to give a presentation on thorough
civil disobedience but he sent his paper
in with one of his classmates and he
didn't show up until the end of the hour
now elsewhere one would think fine you
don't show up for class no big deal but
at West Point things are different and
that should that's perhaps no surprise
if a cadets absent without an excuse or
even late he or she pays for the
infraction was something called hours
you might remember Errol Flynn's George
Custer marching back and forth with his
rifle as punishment for a misdemeanor at
the beginning of they died with their
boots on that's when Olivia de Havilland
walked by and distracts him but he's
supposed to be walking hours and cadets
can still be found marching back and
forth on the area as it's called and
they describe it as a mind-numbing
experience and I've put more than a few
of them there how was your weekend I
asked one of my students one Monday
morning well he said without resentment
I spent most of it walking hours because
I was late for your class last week and
thus one finds oneself connected
implicated in strange ways
with different facets of the cadet
experience one doesn't simply teach
English there's a convoluted cause chain
of causes and effects while a Stephen
supposedly composed his poetry while
walking to work
Stephens poetry might be forever linked
for a cadet to the experience of wearing
through the soles of his shoes on the
area in Andy's absence I read the paper
myself and it was an eloquent parody of
Thoreau's argument that reproduced its
twists and turns with a painstaking
fidelity in short Andy refused to
subject himself to professor Sam it's
arbitrary tyranny by writing this essay
instead he submitted his own manifesto
on civil disobedience and like Thoreau
condemned to the Concord jail for a
night Andy proved willing to incur the
state's punishment for his rebellion it
was a masterstroke and it took guts but
it was exquisitely written pitch-perfect
I'm not sure that every one of my
colleagues would have been similarly
delighted by this
him to disobedience its eloquence
notwithstanding and I admit that I was a
little disconcerted by his failure to
appear until I read the paper and
understood what was going on this was an
intellectual exercise of course not a
field exercise and I knew that and II
could recognize the difference not to
acknowledge the papers brilliance to
interpret it instead as a gesture that
was menacingly insubordinate would I
thought had been to demonstrate a
remarkable absence of humor and common
sense and II wasn't mocking the entire
system but his mastery of Thoreau
brought into focus for him the dynamics
of surrendering his obedience and if
it's true that there would be no freedom
without a knowledge of slavery no virtue
without the knowledge of sin so too
would there be no obedience worth the
name without an appreciation of
disobedience and in Iraq as it came as
no surprise to me and he was strictly a
law-and-order man he was there at the
beginning of the vet invasion stayed
during his first deployment through the
president's mission accomplished speech
on the USS Abraham Lincoln on the 1st of
May 2003 and returned for a short
deployment in 2005 and the letters we
traded I heard a young man coming to
terms with the sometimes ambiguous
mission unlike many soldiers in Iraq and
II had no email access and our
correspondents had a distinctly
old-fashioned feel anticipating a
shortage of paper he had planned ahead
by taking a lot of blank notebooks to
Iraq writing short stories but
especially poetry provided an escape for
him whenever he was not conducting
police patrols and raids building desks
for school children or defusing
landmines Andy's letters are funny and
finely crafted just as his essays had
been the Fertile Crescent he reports in
one is fertile compared to the desert
but not compared to say France or Ohio
in this way he wrote I think it is a
misnomer soon Andy ran out of both paper
and books and hits he had more time for
Iraq in Iraq for both of these than he
did back home his family kept sending
him supplies and I mailed a collection
of plays a short story anthology and
several months worth of poetry magazine
after he received the first curtain
Andy wrote to me I don't know if the
soldiers in my platoon will want to pass
around poetry in the same enthusiastic
way they passed around other magazines
but I will surely try to get them
started perhaps I replied he would forge
an entire platoon of warrior poets
remembering a newspaper story about the
desert being littered with the water
bottles and the wrappers from
meals-ready-to-eat
MREs after the first Gulf War I shared
with him my fantasy that in this war
along with the usual detritus the desert
might swallow up a few books that would
resurface one day to puzzle an
archaeologist the next letter Andy sent
me was smudged dirty water stained his
unit had moved for a time they guarded
weapons stockpiles and then they shifted
to western Iraq to patrol the poorest
Syrian and Jordanian borders the next
few letters he sent were alternately
farcical and dispirited
and one he sent drafts of poems with the
caveat the author wishes to reiterate
that these are the musings of a man who
has little else to do with his time than
sit around then one day he wrote the
Iraqi people have grown tired of waiting
for improvements to public
infrastructure tired of unemployment and
tired of military occupation so it seems
I try to divert him with lines from
unnamed poems correctly identifying a
quotation from Wallace Stevens who was
his favorite
he added I wish I had brought my
collected Stevens along but I didn't
want to get it dirty so I sent him a
paper back that can take some abuse
unlike the expense of cloth edition he'd
left at home the Stevens proved he wrote
to me a great poetic oasis in the desert
its pages are a little sand worn by now
he added but that was the whole point
wasn't it underneath the humor of course
the urgency came through it's a good
thing he wrote that I have lots of books
because reading is the only bearable
alternative to boredom other than sleep
which in itself becomes boring after
many hours Stephens seemed to give Andy
a way of imposing discipline on what he
called his dust infused mind in one of
his poems Stephen Wright Stephens writes
of the Blessed rage for order it is a
phrase that captures for me the military
love of form and measure squared corners
straight gig lines synchronized hands
and feet everything as the saying goes
dress right dress but what Andy
confronted in Iraq had nothing of this
soothing regularity and in Stevens he
found someone else who was wrestling
with a language that might shape his
unruly experience and so when people
asked me today what my function is I
don't have the same glib answer that I
once gave
to that groundskeeper many years ago
thank you I guess the first thing that
just came to my mind when you were
reading those letters was were there any
of your students that have been killed
in action um I have had one student who
was killed and two colleagues who have
been killed and so that's very much
military funerals have something I had
no experience of before coming to West
Point have become part of our ritual
part of our routine
can you tell us some of the other books
that you've taught that have been
significant significant use to the
students or typical level relevance I
would say that certainly the epics the
Homeric epics have been hugely important
I read The Iliad with Cleaves before the
war and I think it and I'm looking
forward to the opportunity of teaching
it again because I think it will have a
very different significance for us than
it did I read The Odyssey with the plebs
after we had after the conflict in
Afghanistan had begun but everybody was
still sort of looking forward at that
point and of course the Odyssey is about
coming home and so there was an odd I
think impatience among the plebs at that
point reading about this post war world
where they had just embarked on a war
and so there was a strange disjunction
then but I find that any books people
often ask when I tell them that we study
texts for example like Tim O'Brien's
books Hemingway and also let's say the
poetry of Randall Jarrell death of the
ball turret gunner for example people
are surprised that we teach literature
about war that doesn't glorify war but
talks about it's grim realities as well
and I think and I know I share this with
my colleagues that it would really be
disingenuous to do anything else that
what's important is for cadets to get
the richest possible the most nuanced
picture of war that they can and I think
literature can help a great deal in that
way because it will not be for these
future lieutenants simply a matter of
displaying their own physical bravery
but they will be responsible for the
lives of others as well and that's a
very different kind of charge that they
have to accept construct your own
curriculum yes we have a set part of the
West Point experience in the core
curriculum which all the cadets take is
the notion of a shared experience
and so we often have in our core courses
a shared syllabus and instructors
variate but certain core texts that help
with that and then in the electives yes
there we have a large selection of
electives and the curriculum changes the
texts we choose change often are there
things that you're told not to teach of
books not to know open their minds - and
I think that's another surprise for many
I have never been told hey I don't think
you ought to teach that the the values
of academic freedom and of free exchange
in the classroom are really hugely
important to the institution there is
attention certainly in an institution
that both trains and educates and part
of the challenge for the cadets is to
figure out where they are at each moment
of the day so if they come to a poetry
class having just been in a military
science class and then on their way to
the parade field to drill they have to
learn to shut that on and off and that's
a real challenge for them and for me
that was part of the growing pains as
well it early on when I would throw
questions out into the void saying I'd
really like to know what you think about
X or Y and they would shake their heads
and say as she doesn't want to know what
we think because in some parts of their
day you know that's not what's required
so you have to be sort of very clear
about the ground rules there but by the
time their upperclassmen they have this
marvelous gift and they know exactly
where they are and what's required of
them in each each venue of preventive
medicine like Biblio there in the throat
literature you mean I suppose and I
guess I sometimes find myself thinking
of literature and yes with a sort of
therapeutic language I guess if we think
of books as weapons their weapons
against against boredom their weapons
against despair and I think literature
can serve those purposes of course
literature can also be very unsettling
and it shakes people out of their
comfort zones and so that may be a
long-term therapy but not an immediate
one right sure I mean I think it does
enlarge one hopes and large ones
sympathies and in particular gives
people a variety of allows us to inhabit
other perspectives which is another
talent that a lieutenant has to
cultivate fairly early on when he or she
has a diverse platoon of soldiers to
lead
you see changes in the students as they
progress from freshman to upperclassmen
both in terms of like their literature
choice and their writings that are
really that you think I really due to
the fact that right now we're in the
Iraq war versus students that might have
gone through West Point during times of
peace is there anything yeah I think so
you see it most I think with the
upperclassmen
there is a sense I mean war was always
of course on the distant horizon no one
goes to a military academy not
conceiving that that might be in
eventualities
but the those professional those grim
realities of the military profession
were not in the forefront when I first
arrived there now it's an immediate
specific context in which they're
thinking about literature and about
their future as officers so in this that
Senior Seminar that I alluded to earlier
one of the projects is to write or to
create a multimedia project in which
they try to make sense of their four
years at West Point and then to look
forward to their their roles as
lieutenants and I find that their
reflections now in that venue are linked
specifically to what they know they'll
have to do as lieutenants and so there's
a there's a there's a real seriousness
of determination about what kind of
lieutenant am I going to be and how do I
make sense of all of this and how do I
figure out my role and so I think that
has an urgency as does the classroom I
think more so than than when we were at
peace
I guess when you think of West Point you
think of male cadets but I know a lotta
there's a lot of female cadets so just
wondering in that your experiences with
female cadets right um yeah they're
about 16% now it ranges but that's what
it is now women cadets and in fact women
at West Point just celebrated their 30
year anniversary and in 30 years a
tremendous amount has changed all to the
good
it was very difficult for those early
classes I think now this is a good thing
cadets think of themselves as cadets
first and men and women second and I
don't know that I noticed a real
difference in the way women approach
literature or the profession from the
way men do and I think that's a positive
certainly being a woman in the army
still has its challenges because it is
historically such a male institution and
a male profession that women have to
find their way in that profession but I
think things have really changed a lot
favorite texts um well I mentioned
Wallace Stevens I like to read Wallace
Stevens a lot with the cadets he's
difficult he's also someone who resists
interpretation there's a West Point in
engineering school it's a place where
facts and calculations are valued and so
some students come in to a poetry class
expecting to find some solution and it's
just that they aren't ready to see it
yet but they think that I know the
answer to it so when we find some
impenetrable poem and Stevens is great
for providing those it's a great place
to illustrate different ways of engaging
with literature sometimes I say I don't
know what Stevens means by this phrase I
love it it sounds good to me it's music
to me but I'm not sure I can figure it
out and that's okay so he said he's
great for that kind of moment I
mentioned the epics I always go back to
the epics to Homer or to Virgil we read
The Odyssey this fall with the seniors
I've read the Aeneid with them several
times and I find that those are some of
the richest obviously the richest
tapestries of war and peace they have
things to say about both
thank you thank you Elizabeth Samet is
an English professor at the US Military
Academy at West Point she is the author
of willing obedience citizens soldiers
and the progress of consent in America
1776 to 1898 for more information visit
192 books.com